This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery setup and mattress
removal.
Christina,
did it have bat bit up, up skidded at
sketch, sketch, sketch. I ended up,
you know I was on the Graham last
week and you texted it to him?
I did and there was a woman on there
to me now so I can just pull it.
Let me find it is terrible.
There's a woman who got
some kind of an award,
like a grammy nomination for scatting.
Not throwing her shit in someone's face.
Scott play is when you play it.
That's a different game hoopoe but it was,
it's probably the most annoying
thing you've ever seen.
I have to search through here.
I don't know Tommy.
It's really great how you don't have
this ready already is just beyond me.
You know?
This is what the show's about babe.
What do you like best about listening
to somebody scan? I mean it's just like,
I just feel it in me. [inaudible] up it
up. I'd be, oh here she is. Here she is.
You email it to me? Yeah. Hold
on. Yeah. What a fucking it,
it kind of feels to me like a racket,
like come on.
It's not really a talent. To me it
feels like someone is really hard.
I just emailed her insides hurts
everything. Well, it's not real.
It's not singing and it's not
rapping. It's scatting, right? Yeah.
So it's like here I,
she's like,
I just feel it. I don't have
to write it, but if I did
set it,
how has that a talent?
If you don't have to write it and you
don't have to really learn how to do it,
we just did it.
Yeah.
Ski.
Well Bart, like it's, Oh God, there
she is. She's got, and it's an NPR.
Yeah. Grammy nominated jazz
vocalists, Jazz. Mia Horn.
Scatting is more than a technique.
It's a means to honor her and ancestry
and empower herself in the moment.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm a greater stage is mine.
You ready to,
you ready to hear my favorite form of
music that exists? Yeah. All right.
Here we go.
Okay.
Think about a horn player.
I just become a horn player.
That did do date.
It's called a kid called
scanning improvisation,
but 10 times because they give out
a whole body is the instrument.
I mean
for me it's important because my ancestors
did it and they had a reason behind
doing what they did.
They didn't have horns.
The reason couldn't afford cool shit.
Yeah, I know, boy. Oh come on now.
It goes to like a fun Jesus.
They will. It's on Instagram.
I don't think about a horn player
B.
Did I just get scared and you got the
grammy num cause I don't know if I could
do that with a horn.
I think if you gave me a horn and he told
me to imitate the horn, I'll be like,
I don't know how to do this.
You have somebody give a try and go
cause that's a talent is what I can go.
I'm a horn.
My ancestors didn't have horns and a,
even though I could go get one
now I want to be like them.
You know my ancestors didn't
have either running water. Yeah,
they didn't have electricity. Sanitation.
We had to do stuff the old way roofs.
None of it beds, but that's
the old way, Yada, Yada.
Preserve the cool stuff, right.
It's the worst is when someone was like,
but people used to do this and
they didn't have what you have now.
That's why he did that. She's like, yeah,
I don't need the horn. I am the horn. No,
you're not, but you're not the horn.
You know, you're not. Honestly,
I don't even like the way the
horn plays just by itself.
I don't like that shit either. I mean,
I like jazz, but even when I hear a lot,
I'm like, oh my God, my
head's going to explode.
One of my friends likes free flowing.
Oh my God,
Jess sessions.
Oh,
and especially when, I don't know
how you wash that. You're like, man,
he's one of those guys like, Oh yeah, I
really loses himself in it, and I'm like,
yeah, he lost me to mission
accomplished now. Damn. Yeah. I mean,
I know there's talent. There's clearly
a lot of skill involved in that stuff,
but for me it just gives me anxiety
listening to it. Yeah, that's pretty bad.
Good night through a proper show.
Open. What are we doing here? Let me,
hold on. Let me do the horns for
it. Yeah, you want to do the, Oh,
you went to your mom's house horns.
Why don't you to all the instruments.
Welcome.
How's really good. Thank you Jesus. My
ancestors taught me. Yeah. Here we go.
Here.
Here you go.
Up Top.
We explain to me why I could eat for it.
If you eat,
eat 10 mother fucking peaks
up consuming as much
as the speaks of pork.
Oh,
is Randy
[inaudible]. Well, welcome.
We'll go to your mom's house
for us,
Christina pledges.
It's interesting.
Wow.
It's like we're instruments not
playing the horn. I am the horn.
I was the guitar right there. Bam,
Bam, Bam. And the thing is my,
uh, to my ancestors, they couldn't
play guitar and neither. Kat,
I'm just carrying on the great tradition
of having no musical talent in my
bloodline. Yeah. Ba, Ba, ba boom,
ba boom. Wow. Yeah. Good stuff.
Truly is. It truly is one
music for him. I don't,
I just don't get, yeah, I don't get it
either. God, you can listen to that shit.
Like,
I don't get it.
A lot of stuff to talk about gene.
Yeah.
So the Christians or are some of them
are against putting their mounts on
penises, right? Yeah. Cause
jeans and stuff. Yeah. The,
a lot of them I think if you're like,
what is it is evangelical
and like old school baptist,
they really read the Bible
literally and then they, yeah,
no,
it really will change your opinion on,
I think religion being a grownup
piano growing up being adult,
any photo from space. Right. You
know, when you look at a photo,
I was looking at a photo from space.
Yeah.
That was taken by some satellite
from Saturn towards earth.
And you just see a dot
and there's an arrow.
It's like this is earth
kind of makes you go like,
it'd be like if someone said,
and then the people on that star
think that a magic man comes down.
You know what I mean? Yeah. It makes
you go like what they read the Bible.
It's a book said to not eat pigs.
It's,
and it's absurd to think that of all the
galaxies and all the solar systems and
yeah,
we only know of this planet having of
life that like we're somehow special only
made up of mythical story.
Yeah. And some, someone,
a man in the sky is keeping track of all
of this. What'd you do that in there?
Did you eat a bite of you suck
somebody's Dick. Did you do you jack off?
No big trouble. Yeah.
Okay. You fuck your mom?
Did you eat fish on Friday? All that
stuff is just nonsense. It, yeah.
I don't think God even has time.
Let's say that there is a god,
he hasn't had time to keep track
of all that. A lot going on.
There's so much more happening.
Especially things like
if you do something,
let's say self indulgent,
it's kind of selfish and greedy.
Maybe it's something
mundane like eating big. Um,
but then there's also
fires and my slot genocide.
He was like, Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, whoa. You have sausage.
Put that back down. Right? Well God
doesn't even care about the biggies.
Like all this stuff you've just named
the fires. And the eye doesn't stop them.
How costs Nazis.
He's always like,
I hope you guys learn freewill.
Yeah.
Better stop being bad.
That's where this happened.
I'm going to send that hurricane and
all those queers. Killary buddy. Yeah.
Stop being gay.
I hate it.
That's one of my main things
up here and I hate gays.
I think about it all the time.
I made you,
I made the possibility that
you gave but I can't stand it.
God's a big homophobe.
Yeah, he really, really
is like, ah, stop it.
Yeah. That's really
cool. So, so ridiculous.
It's just like the gays I know. Got, it's
just like the gate. Just let this guy,
that is God's thing. Right? Here's God
right here. I have a quote from God.
I have come all over my face.
What?
She sent me an MP three. He sent
you that? Yeah. Um, so yeah,
this lady here has like some
pretty strong views. Yeah,
there you go.
It's interesting how, I mean you're
taught these rules kind of early.
If you're a grownup and religion and then
there is a turning point where you go
like, wait a minute, wait a
minute, why can't I do that?
Why can't I eat pork or why can't I have,
cause the guy said,
why is this even like
all the stories make no sense.
No sense.
And also the idea that there's a book
in even in his historical context,
human history, it's like a
hundred thousand years old,
but we're going to like,
but 2000 years ago they're like,
that's when the guy was here.
It's the right one.
And that's when the book was written.
And then people are like,
that's the book.
We all should live our lives based
on a book that's 2000 years old.
He didn't know that. Yeah. Okay. Well,
and also there's two then
all the people before him,
were they doing things incorrectly
or Doug didn't know here yet?
Well, uh, for it when I was going to say,
yeah, I, yeah, it's, it's all fucking
so stupid. Here's what I think.
This is what God is doing all day
long. Every day. Rob, Rob, rob,
just jerking off, watching
TV. I think we're TV.
You think every time he comes it's,
and that's rain. That's a really good,
really good. No, because these guys, so
his comes gotta be, that's the hurricanes.
Oh, it's right. Hurricanes. Tornadoes.
See, that makes a lot more sense.
It's God come when, when there's a
hurricane. Yeah. Or blizzard or something.
We should run this by my mom
thinks she would dig it. Yeah.
It's interesting too, what people have
a couple of religious jokes in my act,
right? Yeah. Yeah, man, it's
so funny. Most of the time
it goes pretty well. Yeah.
But there's been times when it's gone
sideways and it is amazing to me how
seriously people take that
still. Yeah. But like I,
I do feel like it has something
to do with being really,
you're really inundated
with it as a child. Yeah.
And you kind of have to under your
childish beliefs. Yeah. As an adult.
And a lot of people don't. And
you're like, wait, that wasn't,
or the idea that our Bible is
the right one is kind of crazy.
I tell you about the conversation I
had with a woman on the plane. No,
I only talked, I don't have those
conversations anymore on a plane. Um,
so I was sitting there and I dunno,
it was pretty mundane stuff.
And then I saw a peak
at the cover and it was something
about Peter the Apostle. So I'll go,
I said something like, good book. And
she was like, it's really good actually.
He's really good. And I said, oh,
okay. And then said, so are you,
I mean, are you just like studying
for educational purposes or like,
in other words, is this, you know, you
learning something or is this like,
you're just free to join us? She's like,
no, this one, you know, I mean it's,
I'm learning, but it's
what I, you know, I was,
I was looking forward to
reading this and I was like, oh.
And then we started talking about that
a little bit and I kinda, you know,
I didn't say anything provocative to her,
but then I was like, Hey, do you ever,
she said something about, Oh yeah.
She was like, yeah, you know,
it's like when people,
she was like,
do you have you accepted Christ as your
savior? And I was like, sure. I go,
I just had like,
I was raised,
that's what I always say when someone
is how I was raised in a Catholic house.
In other words, I'm trying to tell
them, you don't worry about me,
like don't try to sell me. Yeah. But I'm
also not trying to further, the guy goes,
raised Catholic. She was like, oh,
that's good. And, or whatever. She said,
but then she was like, yeah, you know,
and it's kind of my mission to like,
you know, I try to save people before and
I go, well, what do you think happens?
I go, if they don't, she goes, then
they go to hell. And I go, so you,
do you really think that people go
to hell if they don't accept Christ?
And she goes, yeah. I said, what about
um, cause there's a lot of people,
billions of people that are
another religion. Like back
to what you were saying.
Okay, sure. And you know Jews
dude, I go, do you think they
go to hell? And she goes,
it was a really hard conclusion
for me to come to. But yeah,
so all Muslims go to
hell. She was like, yeah,
and I go and all Jews. She was like,
Yup. And I go, all right, I go have,
have a great trip. Hope you
have a blessed, blessed.
But isn't that crazy that this
human is walking the world with us?
Well,
and especially because if you,
I mean Jesus has messages of love and
acceptance and he accepted the prostitutes
and he accepted all the people that, you
know, we're a marginalized in society.
But except for those, you know,
Jews and then those loans,
I mean I get it.
If it religion gives you comfort,
I think you should have your comfort
for sure. Then your messages,
everyone's going to hell was kind
of a crew. Hey, contradictory. Yeah.
This lady is also a little crazy
in your fucking mouth
and it all falls under
the same umbrella. Yeah.
She said she added a syllable
to umbrella umbrella umber.
She did it at the Rihanna Barella
oh
man.
Fuck you up.
Let's be in a religion though.
It's funny cause I flew home
yesterday from Portland and was that
our audiences are by far the panning
out that these are being recorded at a
different pace because of the
fucking movie schedules. Excuse me.
Because of the Goddamn fucking movie
schedule. You're a movie star now.
You should have no more regal of it.
A vocabulary.
I'm just letting our listeners know.
I mean I'm thrilled to do the movie
and I always love doing this show.
I'm just saying that's why
you're maybe starting out.
You think you should really clean up,
clean up my act of the waste to act the
everything. So I came back from Portland,
which was amazed.
The audiences were amazed.
You guys are fantastic for coming out.
I really do appreciate
Portland [inaudible] have
the best fucking crowds are
just amazing and they're so, they're
so down to have fun. I had, you know,
it was great.
So I know Portland and Portland and I
came home and we were texting and you go,
is it weird that I don't
give a shit about Easter?
Don't give a motherfucking shit about
Easter Sunday as I'm flying home on Easter
Sunday and I will go, neither do
I could give fucking zero fucks.
But I honestly think it's two fold for
me. Why I don't like Easter one. Uh,
because of the stations of the cross.
Because in Catholic school it was like
they didn't focus on the Easter bunny or
on the fund or the chocolate
Catholic school is like,
and then the suffering Christ for
people that listen or watch the show,
we all have different backgrounds,
but the kids that grew up in Catholic
homes know that, you know, Catholics,
if you had real Catholic
parents said a real,
a nice way of ruining child's like fun.
Yeah.
It should just be Easter
baskets and Shire,
they were ruined Christmas with
Christ's suffering and you know,
you're like presence there. Like it's
not about presence. And you're like,
all right. And then you're like,
everyone else was talking about presence.
Yeah,
well they're stupid and they're
going to hell. And then Easter. Yeah.
Easter's like bunny.
And they're like,
well the real part about Easter
as God rose after he was murdered.
Oh four.
So yeah,
but they really dragged it out. When I
went to an all girls Catholic school,
you realize that's why we
fucking go like God, Jesus
ruined before you go.
And we had to walk.
I remember our campus was
beautiful and they had,
they actually did the real stations of
the cross and we had to walk around with
a non, you know, sister Ann or
whoever. And then she's like,
and this is when Jesus fell again and
Jesus falls like a hundred times over and
over.
And they beat him and whipped them and
people point and laugh and he had a crown
of thorns in his marriage.
I remember being a kid and then
showing us that on an Easter too.
What I mean, like not in school. I
mean, being a young kid, you know,
maybe five or six and you're like, have
your basket where you're Chucky treats.
And then they're like, there's an image
of, and you're like, what happened? Jesus,
he's, he rose from the dead today while
you're eating your fucking chocolate.
And then I remember I had this teacher
who had to teach us exactly how the nails
got put in. Did you know that?
They did not. By the way,
it's inaccurate historically that
they put the nails through Jesus,
his palms through the risks. Right.
Because that would slide off the cross.
If you nailed somebody,
palms,
it would just tear through
it and the person would fall.
So they crucified you by
nailing it through your wrists.
But it was cool for them to discover
that I bet back in the room. Yeah.
They were like, Oh, you know the nail,
the weight of his body just slid through
his hands when he fell, he still died,
but kind of fucked up the
decoration we were going for it.
So what we've done is
innovated this whole thing.
We nail through the risks and
then we nail through both feet
and they bleed out. That
way works well. Yeah. Okay.
So that's one reason I hate Easter.
The second reason has to do
is my dad,
I had this childhood memory,
it was right around the age where I
was kind of starting to figure out that
Santa wasn't real.
And I think once that domino falls,
all the others do like the Easter bunny
and the tooth fairy and Santa hadn't
fallen just yet, but I was starting
to catch on and I remember my dad,
I was staying with him at the time and um,
it was the night before Easter and I were
going to sleep and I was like, so dad,
the Easter bunny is going to come
right like these. I kept asking him,
the Easter bunny is going to come right.
And he was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, sure.
It's going to come like it.
Co of course ignoring me.
And of course I woke up Easter
morning and there was nothing like,
my dad didn't even buy me like a
chocolate, like nothing in the house.
And I remember just being
like, wait, there's no Easter
bunny. It's like, oh yeah,
no, there's no Easter bunny like he,
that's how he told me. I don't remember.
It must have been like around the
age where you start to realize,
so let's seven or something seminary.
And then I remember going to my mom's
house and just crying cause like it was
like
there's no,
and she's like fuck. She's like, yeah.
And I remember she took me to the store
and I bought an etch a sketch and that
was like my Easter present for the day.
But like he really fucked up the
biggies for me cause he was just lazy.
He was like, Nah, I don't
want to buy nothing for you.
So that sounds cool
parenting, right? Yeah.
But we don't say, here's the thing is
that we don't fuck up our kids good time.
I keep trying.
I just pull that back.
As much as I don't give
a fuck about Easter,
I made sure that our child enjoyed Easter.
Yesterday we did an Easter egg
hunt for LJ and he got, you know,
we didn't do the Jesus stuff to him.
Yeah. She got to do it for your kids,
man. You got to do it for your kids.
So we don't give a shit. I no, no, no.
That's the whole thing. That's what
being a parent is a good parent.
I'm just saying that that's what being
yes, that yesterday and hiding eggs,
that's us being good, but
my dad was so selfish, like,
why wouldn't you just be like,
and I remember him blowing
me off like, yeah, yeah,
sure, sure. It's going to be
here tomorrow. Yeah. Yeah.
Like it was so dismissive and shitty.
Like you couldn't have gotten,
I know you went to the liquor store.
I know you went down to the seven 11
you could gotten me like a fucking
chocolate bunny with your six or a
Heineken. I mean that's just fucking lazy.
I'm sorry. No, I'm fine.
I'm just saying it's really
lazy parenting. Yeah, no, I
hear you. I hear you. Yeah.
Could have gotten down to the
fucking rite aid or whatever. Cvs.
I definitely think most men
would fall short if they were,
that's true. That's true. You guys have
no, but that's not, not this generation.
I mean all this generation is
different though. It is a different,
it's a different world.
We're also,
this generation is much more
emotionally aware, you know?
I'll be, your dad will probably just like,
oh, here's your, I don't know Steg Buddy.
Here's your Easter steak. Yeah, yeah. Like
steak. And then he'd be like, all right.
Uh, I owe her some chocolates too,
but I don't know where they are.
Okay.
And that would be your eastern,
probably the women kind of
ran the show when it, right.
But if your kid says pacifically, Hey
dad, Easter Buddy's coming tomorrow.
You know what that means? Yeah. Yeah.
A cute little girl asking you for shit.
I mean, come on. Jesus Christ. Oh,
fucking leave. If she has specifically,
I'm sure you would try. It was like I
was reminding him. Yeah. So fucking lazy.
He's unbelievable. She's Christ. Uh,
but you're right, the women tend to keep
up the traditions they do. Yeah. I know.
It sounds like I'm being a antiquated
with this stuff, but it's true.
Well, yeah, I, I'm the mom, so I
make sure Christmas looks nice.
The House looks nice, never do a
decoration. I'll tell you that.
If it was just me,
not a single thing,
you would never know
what time of year it was.
If you were just dropped into this home,
you'd be like, I dunno. Is it March?
Is it June? Is it November?
You had no, no idea. Yeah, no,
but I liked that you do it of course,
because I know it makes everybody,
it brings joy. Just like at
Halloween, I decorate the house.
I like to have that stuff. Maybe because
my parents were so great at it, you know,
I'm just carrying on their
tradition on this circle of fun,
just like my ancestors did.
Yesterday's court blood pressure
come fuck you up on it in a long run.
Fuck you up in alone.
Drawn from the inside.
That's why we got aids and all
this other bullshit around. Okay,
so the term eating, eating
vagina, uh, it, it, it's, it's,
you're more so licky you're
not really eating it.
You consume and the shit that comes from,
you
know,
either I'll be okay.
I love her.
I wish that was my grandmother.
She didn't have a lot of fun in her youth
and her grandmother didn't talk like
that at all. But I wish, I wish you did.
He's why we got eight
Carl from oral. Yeah. And
vaginas and stuff. Yeah.
I love it.
I think it was bud fucking actually ma'am,
but fucking there's the medical
term when you, but fuck,
you can get eight. Yeah,
that's what they say.
So the doctor says that fucking disease.
Yeah.
I don't think it's a dick suck disease.
So not down with that pork.
No. Pork is really a big, the Muslims
don't eat the pork, right? Yeah, no.
Yeah. By the way, did you see this?
You've seen this filthy animal.
They're all filthy animals. Cows
are filthy too. They're all,
they all step in their own ship
to change your filthy animals. Um,
this guy, what is his
name? Jamie. Jamie Lee.
Parker is a tattoo artist.
And I know what you're going to bring
up and I can't believe how good it is.
So I have a,
I have a joke in my latest special about,
which is true about sometimes throughout
my life and including recently,
people will be like, oh,
Segura is that Japanese?
And I have a,
so there's a bit about it in the special
home and do the whole thing. But,
so anyways, I guess, you know,
people have been commenting and
messaging me a lot about it and you know,
they right there. Are you
Japanese like as a joke? Oh yeah.
When people who think it's Japanese
relaxing uha sounds Japanese.
I'm like, alright man.
Anyways, that's the joke.
He did a tattoo on someone,
craziness of me as like a Samurai.
Um,
it's so good.
I mean I will say detail is like,
he really got your face, your nose, your
beard, and you're like the guys really,
whoever this is is an amazing
beard. Colors, right? Yeah.
Like down to the the whisker. Yeah. Like
where, like this white hair right here.
Yeah. I know what you're talking
about. Yeah. And he did a 14 hours.
Damn.
It's a real fan right there.
This is so amazing. Especially in
contrast to that Instagram page.
I think it's called sucky
tattoos or suck my tattoos.
That shit is so fucking hilarious.
Cause it's,
it's basically tattoos that
were done in 14 seconds.
Yeah. It's sucky tattoos. Hmm.
And then the tagline is stopped getting
shitty tattoos. [inaudible] says it's,
it's so unbelievable.
I'm going to try to pull it up
right now and show it to you, um,
that people would, especially when
you see how bad these are, um,
it's like, why would you,
this isn't like you paid,
you bought a painting and your
pride, you're, uh, you know,
you're like, I'm going to hang this
up. This is on your body. You know,
this is on your body forever and
so hard to commit to something.
Oh my God. I mean, that guy says,
it just says keep it real stupid.
Ooh,
I dunno what that's supposed to be.
That's misspelled.
Believed in myself.
P. E. L. I. V. E. N. O. Shit. That's bad.
That says be live in, and this is what
about believing in English? Yeah, I mean,
as shit like this, it's funny.
Eyes on your ass cheeks.
The ones that are really crazy or
just like the really poorly sketched.
Well,
you know where the the line work here,
you know like the outer
edge is and then look,
they misspelled California
and then rode over it.
California dreaming and
I mean look at the font.
It's like somebody free hand.
You let them,
does it make any sense?
You know,
no prison tattoos.
I don't think that's fair cause
it's like that dude's in prison.
Oh you think something's
wrong with this guy though? Or
you think something's wrong with
him? No teeth in the mouth, but no,
but I mean like you can't, you can't
really rank a prison tattoo. It's like,
all right.
Ah Man,
I don't know. Just this they
misspelled too. You know there's,
there's two o's too weird
to live. Too Rare. Yeah.
Yeah.
I thought
they do a stencil first
so you can proof read
like nobody, nobody
proof writers. No regrets
a lot, bro. Yeah. Anyways,
what a great contrast. Right?
When you see this work,
you know that somebody paid someone
for that and then you have fucking
sky that's amaze through this. I think
it's crazy. Jamie Lee Parker. Oh,
Jamie Hart. Yeah. Where do you
know where this person is? No, no.
I just see it in this email here, but
pretty amazing. It's incredible. Yeah.
Jesus even got your silly, I work, I
keep forgetting because I look at it,
I see a painting. Thank you. Keep
forgetting to this is on someone's body.
That's another thing you have to
take into consideration is like that.
That's on an angle. Like yeah,
it's a round surface. Simon.
A flat. It's like an arm.
But even right now I keep,
I keep forgetting as a
looking at it cause I'm looking at the
artwork and then I have to remind myself
somebody is walking around with that.
No, I know. What if you offend him
on your next special, I don't know.
You're like hates me. Yeah. And he's
like fuck fucking eight times bigger.
And now I was like, what's
he look like? And he's like,
well actually I have a photo
like tattoo of him on my body.
Gmo Farms. Is that on his leg? You think
arm? Uh, I dunno. I
can't tell. It's around.
I think that's a leg.
Oh, you're right. I
think you're right. Yeah.
So like not only does he have to get you
in your life, your likeliness, perfect.
Your likeness, sorry. But he has to do
it on an angle. So like how does he even,
how do they fucking learn? How do you
learn to Tattoo? That's the real thing.
That means you got to give a lot
of bad tattoos I'm assuming, right?
I'm assuming. Yeah. But hopefully
most of them are just, you know,
not tattooed on someone. Maybe you
learned all your bad stuff on paper.
You learnt. Yeah. But then, but then you
can practice it. Yeah. Do it on skin, man.
And I'm going to town
right now. So I do this regularly.
Well, because I freak out.
I personally have my own anxiety about
beard length and hair length and I,
you know, when it gets to a
certain point you kind of go like,
I got to get my hair cut today.
I gotta get my,
yeah. Yeah. I get the same way.
I feel like I look horrible.
You got to do it just ugly.
You get your head like
this over a week.
But I can't touch it myself because I
go to shoot more of the White House to
look the same as it did last time,
so I have to go tomorrow and let them
do the cut and make sure it matches the
earlier stuff. Anyways, it's making me
absolutely crazy. Shout out to Plymouth,
Minnesota is suburb of Minneapolis and
wearing my twin cities hat today and
shout out to Zachary Lane. Elementary
school where I went for one year. Okay.
You think a lot of those people
are listening? There's definitely someone
right now who's like no fucking way.
I went to Zachary Lane.
Yeah,
I went there for fourth grade and
then we went to the Catholic school.
I forget the name of fifth grade
and sixth grade raised. Yeah.
It's cool.
Your parents moved you around every
year and then we moved again for seventh
grade. I went to lake shore, Middle
School in medicine. It's really bad.
Did your kids your beard? I don't. I
don't feel like it's that full right now.
I know how full it is compared
to how I've been wearing it.
Do you,
so do you smell the smells
more like it cause I know,
I know that your beard's traps
more smells a little more.
It is a little more trappy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No,
I will say when your diet was way worser.
Yeah.
When you were eating like pizza and stuff,
your beard would smell a lot like like
cheese and stuff more. Thank you. Then.
Yeah. It doesn't smell bad now,
but I can tell what you've,
what you've been doing like memory,
you came home last time and I
sniffed your beard and I was like,
did you smoke cigars? Yeah.
Yeah. I can smell that.
Smoked cigars the day
before. Right. But it's,
it's still in your beard and in your
skin and you hadn't showered. Right.
I'm assuming. I think I had showered.
That's what I was amazing. Yeah.
I can smell it all in your
beard. Yeah. Pretty interesting.
Let you go on your hikes. Who knows
what happens there? Hiking lately,
smelling that beard
meeting guys.
A lot of Nice guys having a muscle spasm
in the same spot for a couple of days.
It's now where spot is it right here.
It's moving right now
on there. You see it? No,
don't you feel it right now?
I wonder why they're right here. I
Dunno. It's interesting. Um, well we're,
we're going to talk about,
I wanted to bring up that Netflix
show you and I got into, uh,
that beach body show. Oh,
with people go to Thailand.
Beauty and the beauty and the
beach or something. Yeah. Yeah.
Thailand for cosmetic surgery. It's
people from New Zealand and Australia who,
who can't afford to have it,
I guess done there.
And then they go to Thailand for discount,
major plastic surgery.
And I'm talking like removing penises,
creating vaginas.
Face Work Major.
Oh yeah.
Major shifts.
Chin implants.
I had no idea how much,
even the discussion of removing
one's penis and testicles.
I would feel so, and I, and I,
this is not to belittle or demean
or humiliate entity does it?
Uh, I think you know, by all means, do
what? Whatever you want to do to be happy.
I think it's great if
that's what you want to do.
I'm saying that when the person
was consultating with the doctor,
I could feel my testes jump,
I could feel my asshole go
like yeah. And he's like, yeah,
and then we'll remove the
penis. I was like, ha ha. Yeah.
And then we'll invert everything
and you a vagina. I was like,
I couldn't, I was, I was having
this visceral reaction to it that I,
I didn't expect at all. It was tough. I
know you couldn't watch the whole segment.
I couldn't watch that segment.
You miss it.
Cause they show the Dong in
her hand at one point. She's
like, yeah, y'all painted.
We caught it all. And he's like,
what? Uh, what did you just say?
I'm joining the Thai accent, ma'am. I
can do it now. My mom is my new moms,
Vietnamese, so I can make fun of rob. Rob.
Yeah, rob. It's fine. Yeah. And his tie,
his tie. Oh He's, yeah. So
he's your rub rub. Dr Rob.
All right. It's, it's fascinating. Yeah.
Yeah.
I guess there's this port,
there's four women in Australia who her
uterus is coming out of her vagina cause
she had five babies and she has like
public health care and they told her she
had to wait nine years to get the
procedure. So she's kind of a fuck that
sizable wait nine years.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
I mean tell someone that their
genitals or is it public health care?
That's what she is on. I don't know.
I'm not familiar enough with their,
the big things about public health care
in different parts of the world is they
will pay for it but they sometimes they're
like you got to come back in years.
Gosh, I mean and in that case
I understand going to Thailand,
it's closer for obviously for Australians.
Yeah.
You get it done and it's a nice
enough place. It's, it's fancy. Yeah.
And there anyway, there's this one
lady cause you, they don't show you,
first of all,
they don't show you a year later,
which is really when you want to see
what plastic surgery looks like was the
very true when the face is relaxed and
you see how the muscles have kind of come
together and the work that they've done.
So you only see like two,
three weeks postop and they're all also
geeked to have the work done and they're
so excited and they're all shiny.
And there's this one lady
who had a facelift done.
Well you tell it. I like
you telling it. She had,
she had a facelift on whatever. She's
all black and blue, which is normal.
And then eyelids all stitched
up. Yeah. Faces all crazy.
And then she's looking in the
mirror. She was like, I look great.
And then about 10 days later,
swelling has reduced. Oh my God.
So brutal. Watch it. I keep thinking
about it. I wish I was a logger,
meaning a transcriber on home, uh, extreme
makeover. It was the name of the show.
Extreme loved that show.
That was the network version.
They would air this show on ABC I think.
And they would basically take people,
busted ass people and give
them a total makeovers.
I mean plastic surgery, new teeth, hair,
great new wardrobes, everything. And then
you know, they would have a big reveal.
People would be like,
what the dog,
they should just have a teeth
make show because that alone,
I remember what just
transform people to were huge.
The teeth were done by a dentist out here.
Oh yeah, I remember that doctor. Yeah,
doctor fuck nuts. Wash bag,
big Douche bag. And He um,
he let us get like free widenings
and we went there and then his uh,
assistance or like, do you have that?
That's where they told me they were like,
you have like 20 habits happened to
me by the way. Later I happened to me.
Same thing. We know, I told that story
for a long time when I had insurance,
dental insurance and this one job and
they're like, you have like 13 cavities,
13th actually the number, that
number. And then I was like, fuck you.
And I went to my Hungarian dentist and
he's like, you have like one cavity,
this is a lie, but this story, whatever.
I'm so I'm glad it's documented because
people have called you out on it.
I asked my friend Eric, I was, he
was there when it happened. Okay.
We worked together. So anyway, go ahead.
When you worked at America's most
wanted so that I know I know that much.
So this lady has like the 10
day she's 10 days removed from,
from her intensive plastic
surgery where they're,
and slides under her fucking
face pulling her drain.
Anyways, she's like, I'm going
to go see the doctor today.
And when she says she's going to go see
the doctor, her left eyebrow, she's like,
I'm going to go see a doctor. I have
someone want to talk to them about it.
And you're like,
I think she's going to talk about that
eyebrow as she goes in there and she's
like, um, there's one thing
I wanted to ask you about.
I remember you mentioning it and I didn't
realize it was an issue until people
kept re-explaining things for
me. Like, I didn't understand,
is this a left eyebrow,
I'm going to come down or is it gonna
stay cock like I'm in a permanent state of
Huh. And he's like, Hey,
we'll come now she had a case of Tom
Cigarettes cause he got that eyebrow.
That's your eyebrows. She had
a case in the meanies. Yeah,
I mean that Shit looked just one.
And I remember dude right before
she went into the dark, I was like,
it's her fucking eyebrow higher
dude. I was like, look, that eyebrow,
it was slowly creeping up.
Creeping up. Yeah. And then
with him it looks really bad. It looks
horrible and he's like, it's very normal.
It will come down under. And I was like,
no way, no fucking way. The muscle him
need full body massage.
Open your mouth.
Let me pull up my, my taste. They do not.
Those doctors are very good.
No, those two, those doctors
pioneered, um, that whole,
you know, cutting the weaning off
surgery. That's what it's called. Yeah.
Dick up inside you,
they created that stuff.
That's why they have so many
good lady boys there. It's,
they, they innovated that.
And thinking about it now,
it's like, uh, I dunno.
It's just that like they in Edinburg.
Yeah.
And so that becomes your canal somehow.
You stay with good sensitivity to, well,
here's how, here's how they did it.
So they took his scrotal skin actually,
and then they show the nurse plucking
the hairs off of the scrotal skin and
making it soft,
like kind of scraping it.
And then that's the skin that they used
for the internal part of the vagina is
when I'm understanding.
And then the, yeah.
And they use the tip of the penis
to make the cliteracy. Ah, yeah.
And then the penis skin, I
think is the outer, the Lavia.
Isn't that amazing? It's
amazing. And I wish they would
have shown more detail. No,
I have so many questions. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. You want to have
that done while they explain
it to you. They're like,
bro, bro, bro, bro,
bro, bro, bro,
bro, bro, bro, bro, Bro.
Oh my God. So moving along, topic
wise. Yeah. You and I went into a bar.
Stocks. Uh, we go, we dropped what we were
taking fifth to the vet I think. Yeah.
And we were on our way back and I had to
go pee in the Starbucks and when I went
to go pee there was a woman next to me
who came in hurriedly hurt hurriedly.
Is that the word? Hurried
hurry. In a hurried manner.
And she dropped trout and
she had a full diarrhea.
Yeah.
Yeah. I have to say in girl world,
that is very rare. It's extremely rare.
It's as rare as hearing a double pipe.
Classic cars.
Generally women don't drop massive
brown load in a public restroom.
Really? No. So what happens? Like,
can you hear a little bit? Oh my God,
I heard everything. No, no. Normally, oh,
ps you hear p number one
only smell too though.
Sometimes some nasty
bitch you'll hear like
and like, like a two will slip out like,
and then you'll know like, oh she's,
she's shitting but you don't sell them.
Do you hear like the full,
like all of it nice world that you live
in because let me tell you something
about the men's room. Yeah. In a lot. In
most place, especially a busy men's room,
like I'm saying multiple stalls.
It is a symphony of sounds
and it smells like death.
I mean, you go to lax. Yeah. Well that's,
yeah. Any major airport like those,
those bathroom stalls are wrecked.
I mean it stinks to high
heaven. Well, at the airport,
you know you've got international dumps,
international time zones dumps,
and you see the, the fucking travel
nurses of humanity walking through there.
Yeah. Garbage, garbage people. Yeah.
No it is. This is like what it's like,
uh,
in the men's room it's like,
but why do you guys have no shame
and why do women have the shame?
Dude do, I mean, I had time in my life
where I was a little more like, Ooh,
but like, I dunno, I think guys are just
like, I got a shit. What do
you want me to do? Help me.
Sensei. Yeah. How do I, I mean I don't,
I usually just shit with reckless
abandon if I have to shit, I shit,
I don't fucking care. Yeah. For the
other gals listening, how do we get them?
How do we get over the hump of,
cause I feel like I would like that
this woman was just going for it.
I mean it was Starbucks.
Yeah.
They basically serve you bal torture and
then some of them don't have bathrooms.
We just heard an eruption though.
I heard diarrhea. Yeah. Very rare.
Very rare in the women's bathroom.
You just got to realize, yeah,
doesn't matter. Doesn't, who cares?
You got it. When you got to go,
you should just let it out.
Let the vowel
and the farts.
I think it's the fart.
So women don't want people to hear
the farts. I hear the sounds right.
It's embarrassing.
It's not lazy like there's,
and there's no one that
you can't see the person.
That's what I always feel
to it was up around you.
It's anonymous and you can wait for that
other person. That's what I've done.
Ones where I'm like, Ooh, like,
and you know the person that I've,
I've heard people go like,
Jesus, I've heard that before.
So if that happens and you're
feeling a little timid, you know,
but I've also walked out and have people
just look right at me and you go like,
yeah,
have you ever had someone after
you violent shit in public?
And then they're like, hey, you're
Tom secure. I know you're a comedian.
I've had them
say, I've had them say like, Hey, yeah,
I'm while I'm at a urinal and I've also
had it while I'm washing my hands. Like,
you know,
but not like after you just
had that like age or dad.
I walked out of the stall,
but I've had it, you know,
washing my hands 30 seconds later.
Right.
They know that you just shit. That's
what I'm saying. I don't know.
I don't know if they know I
just shit, no, I don't think so.
Cause I, that would bother me if I took
a shit. And then they're like, oh hey,
I don't like when they try to
shake my hands in the bathroom.
That's nasty as fuck. I've had a guy try
to shake my hands on at the urinal. Yeah.
Holding your winger.
Yeah.
And I'm like, well, I'm a little busy
right now. He's like, Oh yeah, yeah.
I was going to come see your show,
but I didn't. I'm like, thank you.
That's always the fun I was going to
see ya. But I chose not to. Thank you.
All right. Yeah. Um, so you remember I was
a few weeks ago. I wonder if I have it,
uh,
in here,
there was a guy and he had a proposal,
I think.
Yeah. This is a year I think about
him from time to time. Yeah. Okay.
This is the guy and he's a real,
I'm
looking at and I want
to have kids someday.
I'm prepared to offer $1,000 to the woman
with similar needs when it wants to go
out with me to dinner
at Churchill in Spokane,
you please post a video response,
um,
detailing why you want to go out with me.
Okay. As a really insane. Yeah.
At first we felt bad for him.
Like, oh, that guy's nice. Yeah.
He kind of was just down
really shitty whole. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, but essentially he's like, Hey,
I'll give you $1,000 I have
dinner at a nice restaurant,
but I want to have a family with you. I
Dunno. Anyways, he has another video out.
See, I know. He's like, you should
be under 25 years old. Here's this.
Oh No. How do you, my lap right
now under 26 right now, no frills,
no big titties in intelligence.
I don't care. She's a hood rat,
punk rock or any kind of anything wrong.
She's hot in here right now and my
37 year old big right now. Right now.
Right now. Right now. Right now.
Right now. Already know already now.
Okay.
He's high as fuck. I think
so. I think everything's
worked out or not. It's on me.
Beat me. He's like, he's
like that level of mania.
The, he just came from Churchill's and
he's just, he's just full of steak.
He was like, I enjoyed dinner, but I
want something to top it off. No, no.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. Again, you
don't have to express this feeling.
You can feel it.
You just don't have to share it.
Well,
when you're high on cocaine
or whatever it is, yeah.
You're not really thinking clearly. That's
true. I bet he's coked up. He looks his,
the eyes are kind of wild
dude. Yeah. He's um, he's
not doing so well. Well,
no, but this is a, this is when you make
videos like this when you're on drugs.
Oh, for sure. I mean,
I would argue that the majority of
videos we play or drunk are high.
Hi. We're having anything is everybody
else gets weighed in. Great here. Beers,
use the research on Tullamarine pupils
are dilated. Then you just go with that.
Oh, why won't you do it with me? I
don't need that question answered.
I need right now, right now.
Right now. Right now. Right
now. Right now. Right now,
after 3000 doors giving food away to
the homeless, I think I deserve it.
I think I'm entitled Bloke and
I think that I deserve it. Now.
I'm not going to believe in
your diet or in, you know,
and since I'm not going to
believe in fate and either.
I just want to hear right now, right
now, right now. Right now. Right now.
This is a good one for doctor [inaudible].
I was literally just putting this
on the doctor drew list. Yeah.
I think he's going to say drugs,
but I think he's also going to talk about
mental illness is in that first video.
I didn't think it was mentally ill.
I just thought he was kind of a snobbish.
Yeah, I thought it was
kind of a narcissist. Yeah.
I'm going to go with the double header
of double hitter of cocaine is drugs and
mania. He might be bipolar. Yeah. Some
kind of an episode happened in here. Yeah.
Well that's definitely one for drew.
Yeah. Wow. Hold on. There's a little
bit more of a, see what else this is,
we need to get rid of this age will be
from chicks under the age 26 because it
tell him Murray's research, the father's
35 to 55 you couldn't live longer,
have longer telomeres,
more dinner.
We need to get rid of it and like we
need to get rid of incest and pedophilia.
We need to get rid of it right now.
Get rid of,
what
did you catch that he said we need to
get rid of something at the beginning.
We need to get rid of
this page will be okay.
Age Phobia. Phobia. Yeah. He looks like
the incredible hulk right now. Yeah.
And the choice to go shirtless and a
video is always a bold one and it's always
an indicator. Yes. Um, and we,
we've seen that many times.
Back ground lighting in the drill
was shirtless. Try it out guys.
Shirtless. Yeah. Right. There's a
lot of, there's a repetition here.
Consistency with shirtless. Sure.
You know, who doesn't post shirtless?
Former presidents.
Ceos.
Yes. Anyone not high. I mean, look
at those pupils. Ooh. Yeah. They're,
they're pretty big right now.
He's really in a mania.
Oh, you're only having sex.
You're telling Murray's abundant.
You're just going to get
stressed and anger and,
and make everybody depressed and stressed
and angry as you roll with the guy and
just go fly.
And later in life you have cancer.
I want a hottie in my lap right now.
Right now. Right now. Right now,
18 year olds be kids.
Doesn't matter what subculture right here.
Right now in Spokane, right now to
go out with me on a date right now.
He's just went from 26 to
18 did you notice it? Yeah.
The age keeps getting lower under 26
originally and then he goes 18 I'm like,
whoa, that's a jump. Hmm. Just jumped
eight years. Eight years. Can you know,
be good for head of the subculture
now, right now. Right now. Right
now. Right now. Right now. Right now.
Hmm. That's kind of, you know, that could
be a good jingle right now. Right now.
Right? It could be like a, are
you hungry? Get a Jimmy John's
now. Right now. Right now. Right now.
Right now. Right. You know, right now
he may have written a single. You're
right. Yeah. Very good, Tom. Good work.
Your car doesn't run. Change
the oil on its own. Come on
over to Jim at Jiffy. Leo,
right
now. Right now. Right
now. Right now. Right now.
I like at the angry one. He does
halfway through right now. Right now.
And he's really in a place.
That guy tax day is almost here.
Have you been to h and r block?
Give us a call
right now. Right now. Right now.
You don't already know right now.
Pretty good. Uh, summer's
coming up. Royal Caribbean.
Take the cruise that you'll
remember for a lifetime.
I don't right now. Right now. Right
now. Right now. Ready? No. Ready now.
That's great. You're right. He got his
whole career. He's not even looking into.
Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in
now, right now. Right now. Right
now. Right now. Ready now. Ready now
when we're going to have to use
him for our ads besides try it out.
We've got the right now. Right now.
Download this latest episode of Your Mom
South Park down right now. Right
now. Right now. Right now. Right now.
50 Times down left and right.
And make sure your sore get sharper
and you come whenever you have control.
Now. Right now. Right
now. Right now. Right.
Pretty good. What a psycho.
He's a good ad guy. He is.
He's the ad man who knew.
Yup. Yup, Yup. Yeah. No,
don't tell me you know something. Tommy.
Uh, speaking of mental
illness, how about this person?
The video seems like it
staggers a little bit.
I don't know what that's all about,
but check out this lady.
Here I am a sole fork.
What that means is from nonphysical
energy. So most people in the planet,
there are nonphysical energy
that is projected forth
into a physical human body.
I am nonphysical energy.
This perfect projected fourth
and two and arturian body.
An extra terrestrial body. Hmm. It's a
mom last night I like to hear more. Okay.
Lucky for you.
An extra terrestrial.
Damian has chosen to then project
forth as a human body 12 times.
This is the 12th incarnation.
It's quite funny and ironically,
because before I even came down,
there was an entire control of beings,
arturian beings,
six dimensional beings who even chose
the way I would look in this life.
I just,
I'm also kind of fascinated where you
acquire the vocabulary to speak like
arturians this before. Actually, it's
not just one word I'm saying. You know,
she,
she's able to speak freely with
some command of basically language.
Most people don't.
It's a glossary of nonsense.
That's a great title for your next album.
I love it. Yeah. Yeah. It's like
how does she come? How did they,
I guess all these Weirdos that buy in
to this shit or she's read some weird,
she read some bullshit book
about, you know, the, the Seti,
whatever messages of
extra terrestrials the,
now there's a whole subculture want
to go full circle on this episode.
It's basically no different than
the Bible. Just a bunch of nonsense.
Did what now? What are you talking
about? The same. It's the same thing.
Kinda.
Would you like to know what,
so I came down here with the intention
of reaching people in every single
continent. They like to pay attention
to what's attractive, right?
But based on where you are geographically,
certain things are attractive and
certain things are unattractive.
So a really beautiful
woman down in Africa. Mike,
come up here to us and be
considered pretty ugly down there.
Why is it we up?
We see in the continent of Africa,
not all down there.
Well,
the earth is flat.
It's not like my looks are so
gorgeous to one demographic over.
Another demographic is that there will
not be a person on the planet regardless
of what country you go to that does not
perceive some level of attractiveness.
Gus, they'll pay attention.
She basically just said,
I'm attractive to any to everyone
on earth. Oh, oh, okay. I, I like,
I didn't want to devote the mental energy
to figuring out what horseshit she's
talking about. She said that she like
I out halfway through it I was like,
I don't, I have, he said, I'm attractive
to iron on earth. To some degree.
That is what this person just
said about themselves. Cool.
I'm attracted to everyone.
18 to 26 we could set her
up with $1,000 state guy.
They seem like a couple of delusional.
At the very least,
people we've heard of make $1,000.
Hey, that's money in my pocket.
She might not be under 26 now. She's too
old for him. How will you think she is?
32 oh yeah, she's way too fucking
old. One foot in the grave,
a soul fork.
This is the 12th incarnation.
Oh Wow. Yeah. Those are drugs.
Right? Or maybe she's just sick, you know?
And I also think there's just
people that are so wounded and they,
they really just need
something to believe in.
And like aliens and incarnations
and spiritual forks and all like,
you know, I am a spiritual fork. Okay.
Okay. Hey Man, it's your world.
You got it. Yeah, go for it.
I can bullshit. Speaking a
spiritual forks. I was in, um,
the airport and I saw a woman
wearing a house slippers,
like fuzzy house slippers.
And it's actually not the
first time I've seen that.
It's, I've been seeing a trend of young
girls wearing like house slippers out.
It's kind of a thing now. Yeah,
I've seen that a lot more. Right.
It's not the open tonus cause
somebody commented like,
Oh do you hate feet is Otr as
like now it's not the feet.
It's that these shoes are not meant
to be worn out in the streets.
They're covered. They have an open back,
you know. So sorry. Which one? Slippers.
Just having an open back.
That's what these were. These
were like fuzzy slippers,
like you know, old school, 1960s fuzzy
slippers. So they were, there was no heel.
It was just like a Shitty, it's a
trend. It's a shitty flip flop. Yeah.
Not even a flip flop. It's got that
one bar so your toes are exposed,
your heels exposed. It's really not
a supportive shoe. It's a crummy,
a soul. You know, I've seen it.
I've seen all different versions.
I've seen the Sandal version where you
see the whole foot, but it's just covered.
It's like fuzzy. But I've also seen
like the house slipper, in other words,
your foot slides into it. Oh God.
Oh right. Yeah. It opened back only.
But it's clearly a slipper.
But I think it's just,
I think it's a fad where the the fad
is like the more that's meant for home,
the more you're seeing it out.
Yes.
I'm saying that it's a statement like
this is such relaxed where I take it out
cause that's how chill I am.
Right.
I wear my pj's and my slippers when
I'm out and I saw a lot of boys wearing
pajama bottoms, like
straight jammies. Oh yeah.
I like to really like Jeff [inaudible]
did a standup in them a few weeks ago. No,
he didn't. No bottoms on stage. Yeah.
Wow. It's Jeff tape. He could pull it off.
I'm just saying that's how relaxed he is.
He's that guy though.
You believe that he just rolled
out of bed and did stand out? Yeah.
Well I mean like it is diet. Look at his
whole Gatorade on stage. He did. Yeah.
Gatorade and hot dogs. Hot
Dogs. We did bring Gatorade.
You know what I remember about that week
that he stayed with us besides when we
lived next door to a seven 11 that's
all he ate. But that's how we got that.
You're saying, excuse me, is that
when he would drink the red Gatorade,
he would have a ring around his lips,
red and his beard.
It would like the color would
bleed into his beard too. Yeah.
So it was kind of a neat bonus with the
Gatorade drinking Gatorade and he had
the full sugar, not even like the g
two, which is what you like to get.
Like when you're sick you get
like the lesser sugar Gatorade,
like serious diarrhea. Yeah. Uh,
then I will have some electrolytes,
electrolytes.
The GTO drink it regularly.
I don't like, no, no.
We have it as an emergency for
when you have diarrhea, diarrhea,
like Chicago,
Chicago.
The funniest thing is we were joking about
Chicago once about like as a nickname
for it. And I kind of laughed at it and
didn't really, you know, he's like, oh,
he has a joke name.
And then I went to the
airport and this lady,
it's a lady in the United Terminal.
Uh,
if you fly United out of lax,
she's a black lady in maybe her
somewhere between 45 and 55 and she wears
sunglasses. But they're clearly
like prescription sunglasses,
but she wears them at the gate.
So you,
she stands out because you're right,
the woman has sunglasses on and she was
like flat 1528 to Chicago was born in
now she said it and I was like,
Oh yeah, what? And anyways,
I saw her a couple of weeks ago and
I said, is there a flight to Chicago?
Because Chicago goes out of gate 57.
Yeah.
I approached her and such a
car and she to Chicago. Well,
I hear,
I've heard lots of people say Chicago.
I think I didn't really pay
attention to the series.
Oh cause that's one of the first
ones that I really, I mean,
I saw her do it over a year ago,
but I wasn't really key on
Chicago. Oh No, I've heard it.
It's very prevalent. It's a common,
a common thing. People say Chicago.
Oh yeah, I've heard Washington,
Washington. I've heard that
too. And it's like, wait,
what? That's terrible.
And uh, Euston my dad's.
But when Washington is,
it's not forgivable.
It's not worship when you cancel a
friendship for sure. So it was like,
I'm going to Washington, Washington.
Nice, stupid. Fuck. It's not Washington.
It's not Chicago. Chicago. Why do you,
why are you throwing a heart in there?
Why people do,
but why?
Why are you adding a letter
that's not even remotely close to?
What I hate to is people who call San
Francisco Frisco because the natives do
not fucking call it.
It's just terrible.
FRESCA and no one says that when you
live up there, it's San Fran. Yeah.
He never say friscol.
It's fucking rocky time.
San Francisco.
[inaudible] 69 [inaudible] 69 is the
football team in a frack and Frisk Frisco
again. April 29th I'm going
there. When are you going
there? I don't have it. Well,
I do have it on the books.
I'm not allowed to announce it yet,
but it's not for awhile.
I did almost saw that date.
I'm almost sold out for cops.
Frisk, man, disco frick, farks men.
This goes, I'm going to
go. I love that city.
April 29th that's when the Jews will
flow in the streets at nine Cobb come
company rain. Come on.
Everybody who goes to my shop,
that's a way of thanking them.
Just me, just my audience members
and Peyton Lafferty and I'm a ball hog.
You are paying Lafferty.
I keep thinking about
the name Peyton Lafferty.
I couldn't help but look right and
what's her career? Tell me everything.
I mean she's done more than that video.
Yeah.
Well what's her,
what's her genre?
She just does her job well. What
does she entered? Double Anal.
I think she's just your run of the mill.
Like what do you need to do?
What do I need to do today?
Kind of the the handyman like the
guy who does all the jobs are like,
she's goes to work, it gets
her job done. She was like,
hey tonight there's a
double headed dildo in you.
Then there's a couple guys
you know banging you tomorrow,
then you need to hook up with a girl
on Thursday. And she's like, all right,
I'm here to, I'm here to work. So her
agent is like by any means necessary.
Like kind of,
I have an audience today and strike me as,
I mean I just kinda looked at a run.
It wasn't like the most intense thing
you've ever heard of and me to look at a
list or something. She's like a day player
cause I, I'm wondering do these girls,
she's kind of all over and Shondra is but
dig, do women generally choose a lane?
It's I me like you don't have Bella.
Donna is like, she know that she,
she's raft like she'll do a
baseball's a reddit thread about,
about us talking about her pain love or
that Paul Blah for blah blah blah blah
blah.
Hog Lafferty.
Name Peyton Lafferty. I wish you'd
think of my show business. Yeah.
I don't think she, I mean according
to this thing, here she is,
she did a few different things.
I don't want to pull up a porn thing.
Is there such a thing as like a porn star?
Wikipedia kind of took us there.
You can see there I MDB and stuff. Oh
you can? Yeah. Yeah, there is. Yeah,
the Porno imdv this one here,
I think you can get away
with showing it Baja Og.
See what you see a lot farther.
Right?
Like you see here we go, QT
Peyton Parker, but it says, oh,
is that who that is?
Peyton come hungry.
Pain Lafferty outside sucking
hard dick. Yeah. Pain laugh.
Are you bouncing her bubble blood on a
hard cock? So it's pretty run of the mill.
There's nothing sucking Dick.
The category small.
It's hardcore anal. Yeah. It's
pretty run of the mill. No soon.
Deep Ass screwing things. Yeah. Yeah.
She did her thing and stuff like that.
That will always be remembered
as a ball hog. I feel like she,
that site said she retired.
Yeah. No longer in the game.
I don't know. And she's so young. She
current career is just beginning. No,
she's in her thirties some porn that's,
yeah.
You ready to do your Guelph porn,
Kim and scenes I came here.
I'm a grandma. Sexy Plasma.
She loved pornography.
She loved man.
Oh yeah.
She's one of the real prize class brass.
Where's she from?
Kim?
It was Kim.
And remember she,
she definitely says it in that one video.
We used to play Fam Thailand's yeah,
I think so.
Hi,
I'm Kim
and I'm here to fill.
This is such a beautiful villa.
The villa we sitting with the first time
ever experience in my life with young
men and they have big,
hard car to offer me.
This villa is really quaint
place and it's really,
really comfortable with a lot of artifacts
inside the house as well as outside
the
viewers.
I want to go do you think that the men
watching are super stoked to hear about
the artifacts?
Probably.
Probably a lot of art collectors and we
watched all the money in the world last
night. Great. How funny was
that? Well, we're halfway.
I fell asleep halfway through it,
but John, Eddie, you're good friends.
Mark Walberg is in it. Sorry.
You were just talking about
it from my friends with,
um, that's one of my
good friends. So anyways,
my buddy marks in it and
I'm kind of out of shape.
Yeah. I'm going to tell him not really in
shape and you're getting fat again. Uh,
who plays the mom? Michelle
Williams. Gosh, she's so great.
She's great in it. This is
the infamous film that, uh,
Kevin Spacey last shot about 50 days.
It was shot ready to go, ready to be
released 47 days before it's release.
This the, it comes out that he's
trying to fuck accused the fucking
teenage boy under age boys.
And he's a huge,
huge how allegedly allegedly
allegedly harassing people,
allegedly going after
underage guys for a long time.
Anyway, that, that's
the storyline. They go,
we can't do this movie with Kevin Spacey.
It's all ready to go.
It's edited already.
So then Ridley Scott,
the director says,
I'm going to reshoot all of his scenes.
This isn't already
completed films so crazy.
And he cast Christopher
plummer at as the reshoot.
Uh,
so they have to bring in actors that
he's obviously in scenes with and reshoot
those again, those scenes. Girl, boy,
boy, girl. Right. But isn't that amazing?
So what they did was the editors sent the,
edited the scenes with spacey to set
and they would see how they were lit,
see how they were blocked, shot
everything. And then they would mimic,
they'd go to the same space that they
just had and they would reshoot it
basically exactly the way they did before.
But with Christopher plummer
instead of Kevin Spacey, it's crazy.
The thing of course,
it's amazing is that even though spacey
is a bigger star than plummer, I mean,
you watch plumber and he's actually
an elderly man playing an elderly man,
which makes sense, right? As opposed to,
he was all in makeup to
make them look older,
but the character was amazing.
It was based on the real
John Paul Getty who, uh,
was a infamously wealthy and stingy man.
And he had such, like, there
was some things we were
really laughing at like, uh,
as well as I am sure a lot
of rich people experience,
they get letters about peoples hardships
and want to know if the rich person can
help them. So this, you
know, they're in the movie,
he has his grandson reading him a letter
that someone wrote, dear Mr Getty,
you know, my, uh, brother needs
a liver or he's going to die.
And I would hope that you can help
us out. God bless. And he's like,
he dictates to his grandson.
He's like, write dear. So and so.
If I gave money to everybody that asked
for help and I'd be destitute like you,
I also so funny that made us laugh so
hard. What a shit head that'd be poor.
Like you.
Boy,
it would be important some of the
vigil you and you know what I mean?
One of the things,
I mean there's not that necessarily
didn't necessarily have it,
but in real life when his grandson was
really kidnapped and the kidnappers did
demand ransom,
he wouldn't pay his own grandson.
And you know in the movie they have him
saying things that he probably really
said, which was like, I'm not paying
that. And they go, even when his,
a guy that works for him is like, you
know, it's a drop in the bucket to you.
And he's like, no, because if this
thing doesn't work out, I'd be exposed.
I don't really have any money
to spare things like that.
Or he had a pay phone in his house for
guests. That was great. Yeah, that's real.
That's real.
He had,
he had a real pitiful in so that you
wouldn't make long distance calls on his
dime
and then he would do his own laundry by
hand and hang it up in the hotel room.
Now it's amazing.
Yeah.
It's such an interesting personality
trait to have so much money. The,
I had billions of dollars and
yet he wouldn't spend, it was,
I wonder what's going on.
But you know, he'd been,
he lived this very luxurious,
I mean,
the homes and they were
outrageous, you know, and he's,
he was perhaps the greatest art
collector in the world. I mean,
you look at the Getty museum's now
and it's unbelievable what was in his
personal collection, but he wouldn't
spend it on, he'd spend it on art,
but not on, you know, laundry
service. I mean, like, yeah.
Little convenience is like that.
I mean,
see, to me, that's the only reason
to have mine. That is the reason.
Can you park closer?
Yeah. And uh, you know,
it's $25 to park here. Okay. Can I
not do my own laundry? Like that's,
that's fantastic.
That's why you have money.
You don't have to do all
those annoying things in life.
He a, yeah, it's gross. When someone's
that rich and his pension at that heart.
Oh my line billionaire. I don't like
that at all. I don't like that either.
What's the point? What are you willing
to do with all your money? I hate,
I hate it.
What I hear, I mean, I guess I like cars,
but I also hate when I hear about rich
guys drive in like whack ass cars and
like the fuck is wrong with you man. I
love cars. I know that, but this ones,
it's really reliable. I get
great mileage. Make you rich,
the fuck are you doing man?
Live a little.
I know.
I get upset when I hear rich people not
spending money on like education for
their kids or they're like, we're sending
kids to public school. I'm like, yeah,
but it in California and a nice,
I know that some public schools are great,
but where we live it's really
not fantastic for the most part.
It depends on your neighborhood, right?
But it's like to just spend the money.
I'll fucking send your
kid somewhere. Nice. Yes.
If it's a, if it's, it's a, it's eat
that. Well, it depends on which, uh,
what part of the country
and what, what, you know.
Yes. No, I know. I know, but
I'm saying that there's a,
I'm thinking of a specific
family. Oh, that we know. Yeah.
One of the best schools I ever went to
was a public school. It wasn't California.
That's true. Bottom of the barrel. That
shit. There's definitely a New York,
New York is good. No, there's
some like regional. Yes.
Obviously. But yeah, I don't,
it know, that's my, I actually wish I
could have gone to that school from,
we went about. What about people
that don't fix their teeth?
The have all the money in the world.
That's fucking crazy. We've seen people,
we know people like that.
Yeah. So it's, it's nuts. I know
where you're like, you don't want to,
it's what everybody sees. First thing
they see your fucking dirty mouth. Yeah.
Fix it.
Get your two fees fixed.
They're colored and
there's holes in there.
It doesn't look like you
know how any of it works.
[inaudible] you will see some wild shit.
This guy who also doctor drew could give
an evaluation and I'll put that on the
list. Goes to in the Burger King Margaret
came and he kind of start some shit.
Hey.
Yeah,
look at that though.
Oh,
so he is talking shit knocking shit off
the counter and I think he just pushed
her register off the counter. Oh,
that's a pretty aggressive. Okay.
Pretty good
clock him.
He's kind of thing on his leg like a
brace. He was being all aggressive.
I know that too. Just clocked him
hard. Yeah. Well he needed it. Okay.
To calm the fuck down.
Hold on a second.
No,
we're standing on his head.
He ain't,
he's got a good reason to Jesus Christ.
Come on up.
I say stay on that fucker's right.
She said no, just to get up.
I'm going to tase his ass.
Yeah.
Good for her. Crazy mother fucker. Good.
He's crazy. He's out of control. Oh, she
came up.
She's just kicked him again.
Yeah,
I dunno how funny this is Tom.
Huh?
Okay.
What part's funny? So you were
getting tased or kits? Well,
it's just that he's getting
it because he deserves it.
He went in there and started
some shit and then stranger,
like that guy that just came in and
slapped him doesn't work though.
He's just a patron that was
like, oh, I can get in a slapped.
So she just, first of all, it's one
thing if you act out and then like,
like that first guy punched him because
he, he, he shoved him first. It's like,
all right, now he's laying on the
ground and someone was like, hold on,
I'm going to tase them.
Like he's already down.
So she goes to tase him and then she
gets in a little phase and
then this guy comes in slack,
kicked and tased again. Ooh. Oh.
I do think the slap was unnecessary.
The head slap. It was, it was,
that was a bonus. Slap wheelies, a bonus
lab. He didn't need that at that point.
Not entirely,
but you can justify it for sure.
I definitely think the Taser was good.
That was a good move on her part.
Tasing some ass. Go girl. Get them again.
This guy's out of his fucking mind.
Yeah. Get out of their asshole.
Good for them.
Yeah. Defend your soul book. And he
has something. He just, this is his,
this thing here at the end. He just
grabbed something there. Oh, Mike,
something like he parked there. Can
you see what it is? I don't know.
Like a wheelchair or a little wheely
thing for all the A's. I got like a scoot.
Scoot for his leg. Oh yeah. Of scoots
goods has a scoot scoot and he's,
he's talking shit and burger king
is crazy. Wow. That's pretty wild.
Yeah. Well Deb, shit, that was great.
Start some shit made my day.
I don't know if I feel the
same way, but really, I mean,
I just wish she hadn't had done
that in the first place, I guess.
I mean, you know, you go into Burger King,
someone says you go into
Burger King on one leg yelling,
push it off the counter, uh, start
talking shit, getting peeves,
people's faces. How do you
think it's going to go? Right?
Like, is that a good idea?
I'd be like,
mm,
gotta be so retarded.
I don't think I would do that.
So he's definitely started some shit.
Shit.
Some shit. Crazy person.
Yeah. That's completely
unnecessary. Well good for them.
They defended themselves. Psych. I could
have gone way, way crazier to man. Um,
somebody wrote to us on or something.
You want to answer that?
Why don't dogs have to wipe? I
have a question for you. Mommy's,
why do dogs not have to wipe
their ass after pooping?
But humans do. Justin from
Portland. Yeah. Well I don't know.
I don't know because I actually think
our dogs need a wiping sometimes because
we've actually had the white bits.
He's a pooper after, after a shit.
So they kind of do sometimes I'm guessing
because their glands or anal glands
are stronger, maybe able to
pinch it really comes off, right?
Yeah.
But like I've said,
we've had the butts stamp on
several pieces of furniture
in this house. So yeah,
it's remember at fie fuse to
do it a lot back in Redondo,
we had a carpet that I got from like
some cheapy place, Ikea or something.
It was covered in
dog shit. And that means my
brother or sister in law.
And I were wondering what
you thought about which, uh,
which of a conjoined twin pair would
have to push to piss the person you
horrified by even entertain the subject.
But I'm sure we are not the only curious
ones about the question. I mean a mommy,
Tina tore it up an SLC, uh,
best show I've ever seen it.
Wise guys ever and way to go.
Thank you. Thank you for the car.
Well that's an interesting question.
They're saying who initiated the puss
when they're, when they're conjoined.
But from what I've seen from the
interviews with conjoined twins,
all those questions about who does what,
it's one of the phenomenons of
what happens. It's neither one.
They both do it at the same time.
So you're telling me they both feel
the urge to shit and they both just,
it's the same. Like how do you
know which leg to put in front of?
Like who goes first? It's just,
it just happens on radical. Yeah.
So there's some things like you,
you just have an automatic body
whereas they share those organs.
And then who initiates masturbation?
That's the same thing.
It's like I feel like coming and the
other ones like me too and then they just
go for it.
Some of those hoes are
married. Those co-joined. Yeah,
those co-joined thoughts are married.
Yeah.
Even I know that's silly.
True. Do you think so? No, they are.
One of them's married and the other one's
not. I think two of them got married.
How the fuck that guy
marries both of them.
Then he married one and then when she's
just along for the whole marriage.
Right. Of course. That's how
they live their life. That's
terrible. So she wouldn't,
she would if she doesn't
want to be married, that guy,
cause she's married that guy to know the,
they both have their own husbands.
God, you're just blowing my mind right
now. So they all say goodnight, goodnight,
goodnight. And then those guys end
up being like, hey man, all the time.
Who's going to fuck her?
But did they have one vagina or to
stop it so the guys take turns.
It's like my night, it's my night.
Sometimes I go in there together.
No, they doubt. Sure they do.
Yeah, they do. She doesn't do
dps. I didn't see that as a DP.
Double Vag. I'm sure our
audience will inform us of
whether or not she's gone. Oh,
I know there's a lot of experts out there.
I can hear them typing right now.
He hasn't found it was released March
8th two guys get your information strain.
You guys are not fact checking on this.
Yeah, we know. We need to know the truth.
Want to get to the real state in Lafferty.
Lafata I'm a ball hog.
I am paid 10 Lafferty.
It's too bad she's in retirement.
I feel like we just boosted her career.
You know what? I know I would. I would
have her in studio just to talk about,
talk about that clip that day.
How'd that feel to be a ball
hog and what was that like?
Was it funny to you when they told you
about the, I mean those poor women,
cause it's dumb things they have to say.
And men actually,
there's all these silly things. I mean
you, you gotta be able to sell those diet.
Let's stupid dialogue.
Just like on any TV show or thing you're
doing with those balls. Yeah. Yeah.
Like it's all part of Showbiz.
What's up Mr High and Mrs Tight.
Big Old fan of both. You notice y'all
burp some times on the podcast? Yeah,
I can't do that for as long as
I can remember. I rarely, Burt,
I've tried many times. Please friends
have described how to do it and nothing.
I can't drink a lot of beer
at a time because of it.
I just get full when it happened.
What happens is I will Burt maybe once
or twice a month and even then they are
always puny little wimpy burps.
This means the odds of me being
blessed with a double pipe classic.
Extremely rare. It makes me sad now
when it comes to farts. Oh my God.
Do I fart a lot. That's my gut is
a toxic waste pant plant. Anyway,
just thought I'd let you know. Keep up the
good work. Gene Salute Jake. Well yeah,
I think you just nailed
it, right? So it's going,
it's going down instead of going up. He
just didn't ever goes up for him. Yeah,
I mean I'd be sad. Well,
without burps I have,
I know somebody very dear to me and
get close to me who can't burp either.
It's a girl and I've tried for a year.
It's been like situation like I
don't want, I won't go there. Okay.
But I've tried training her
and we tried sewed. I've tried.
There's different things you can do.
You can,
I say it'd be okay,
but you can't suck in the air.
You can train yourself to burp that way.
See,
I just did that on command.
I can do this guy says he can.
He drinks a soda and nothing happens.
What happens is he farts
choosing to go down.
But you think that's like what is going
on in this person's body where that
happened? It's just the way they're
built and yeah, it sounds like it.
I mean I don't Burp as
much now that I'm pregnant.
I think cause I have so much acid
reflux happening and I don't want a burb
look at you. You just did
that. You just did that.
That would have made his whole
year. Wow. Maybe it just did.
I think some people are more inclined
to be burpee than others. It's a gift.
It's a genetic blessing. All
right. Yeah. I don't know.
You can train. I mean, you
have to suck up the air.
Have you tried sucking
it up from your stomach?
Like I just did that. Yeah. I don't
understand. Just I just did that.
Swallow more air and then put the swallow.
It's not, he said that he swallows air.
It's bringing it up and does and to
sound that's causing him trouble.
I don't know how to teach it.
I don't know how to teach it though.
I feel like there's just some things
that you just know in life, you know?
I agree. It's an innate
skill, guys. I just is.
He's just not your calling now, next
lifetime or anything else, June?
No. All right. How about you, Eugene? I'm
good. Yeah, we've got to wrap it up. Okay,
let's go finish our John Paul Getty
movie. Okay. Alright. I love you.
I love you.
It's a stupid, Huh? All right. Bye guys.
Thanks for listening to the
show and see you next time.